[Music]
first we will control the center by how
what will be the first stage of
controlling the center e E4 or D4 we
don't need to be specific speaking in
principles is much easier we will have
one or two pawns on the central squares
right perfect then we will develop the
knights usually first the knights
Bishops with we will Castle why we will
Castle get ouring safe because our Pawns
in the center went to fight for the
Center Square so we move our King to the
side and get it safe and then we will
continue the developing okay so this is
just logical way how to play chess but
then we were touching something else
developing the pieces in the right way
is great but but what is even more
important than that material material
keeping
keeping a great balance of how many
units we have right so for that we
mentioned that we want to do well
practice if you are a basketball player
and you want to improve your free shots
what will you
do
practice anything you know when I grew
up I think I said it here once my
biggest her I know that shows you how
old I am was Larry Bird in the ' 80s in
the Celtics and if you read a lot of
articles with him about him he wasn't
the most athletic person in the world
actually quite far from that but he was
one of the hardest working you know
saying how in high school and he used to
wake up at 5: in the morning shoot all
depends what you with 500 f r and then
you know starts his days and became one
of the greatest shooters ever in history
and again not the most athletic person
you would imagine but one of the hardest
worker ever well in chess we need to
shoot less rituals but we will do many
many more puzzles because that's our way
of practicing if we will see the same
idea the same pattern just is so much
about pattern we'll see the same pattern
10 times 100 times 200 times 500 times
Well it becomes so so easy so let's
start with our puzzles and there are
some absolutely several great book for
kids puzzle books like some of them by
Susan pogar that I can recommend yaser
San that is well the lead GM resident in
this club wrote some great books
including combination and tactical one
tiny bit with less puzzles and examples
in them but excellent ones and there are
many other if you just go to you know
ask your parents go to Amazon and just
type chess puzzle books you you will
have enough and most of them are written
by excellent authors so you can see them
so let's start with our puzzles before
that which tactical ideas we have to win
material by doing puzzles like how can
we win material in chest for
example a fork anyone heard about a fork
other than the one in the
kitchen yes what would a fork be in
chess it is when one piece or
one it has two pieces at once two pieces
or more right it's at least exactly so
just like the shape of a fork it's
attacking it's touching more than once
so two pieces or more and what is the
idea of a
fork a knight no a knight is the one
usually doing Fork the other will we
will call them double attack but what is
the idea of a fork what's the idea of
all those tactical puzzles one idea what
is it here let let me show let me show
you super basic position okay white is
down tiny bit material
but white has a way to actually equalize
the game yes Knight C7 Knight C7 and you
are foring which pieces the king and the
Rook the King on E8 and The Rook on A8
and by doing so are you going to win
material yes how many points are you
going to win five three five three two
two
502 you're going to win you're going to
win five but you Mo no but you're you're
going to lose you're going to win two
two thank you if they do the right yes
but but but our assumption in playing
chess is always always should be I I
want to play the best move and my
opponent is going to play
his move yes and if he plays less you're
very happy but if he doesn't well you
cannot build anything on saying okay
I'll play this move my opponent will
play a mistake um okay then don't study
the chest just go and pray you know
worship whatever you do and you know
your opponent will make a mistake if you
want to play the right way it's exactly
what you said I play best move my
opponent play best move I play best move
my opponent play best move what is the
position no other way to think so any
other folk in this
position yes Knight F6 Knight
F6 okay exactly exactly same idea now
let's think about some positions in a
tiny more complex way that's perfect so
we will we can use forks in order to Wi
material white is to play in this
position a bit more difficult but I can
tell you that white has a way to win
material
here I will let you answer first but I
okay there's
another yes um this should
Bishop takes the Knight why do you want
to take the
Knight so that c very good very very
good that's what you were going to say
okay so two times very good and when the
pawn takes the
Knight then what Knight excellent so
actually what were you doing by Bishop
takes Knight you were doing something
else you
were you your final idea is Fork perfect
but before that you had to what what how
would we a book mention this sacrifice
is this a sacrifice why did you
sacrifice you didn't sacrifice you
exchanged but you did something with
this
exchange PA is double the pawn what I
care about no no we care about being
able to play Knight C7 but I had to do
yes the
deflection I had to remove move a
Defender this night yes you are correct
all everything that you said Is Right
doubling the pawns on any day would be
nice and it's nice here but it is the
least important of why white played that
why did white play it because he want to
remove to remove this Defender
from d square for example let's see
another puzzle with exactly same idea by
the way it is a much higher level that
was very good way of thinking it's
already being able to see two moves
ahead basically what you tell yourself
you tell yourself I want to play Knight
C7 but Knight D7 right now is not going
to be as efficient because the opponent
is going to take it so I will first
eliminate this Knight then I will play
Knight C7 this is really what makes a
chess play sometimes it is one two moves
ahead many times it is many many more
moves ahead to be able to to calculate
the lines for you and your opponent
let's look at somewhat similar
idea okay white to
play well you will answer but wait I
just want to see one or two more hands
and you'll answer I want to see more
hands okay many more hands yes Queen D5
check Queen D5
check and what is your double attack
here the on G and
the okay perfect
okay well yeah actually you're right
it's going to be Checkmate pretty much
very good okay now let let's see very
good well if he doesn't move into the
corner but he has to move to the corner
because you cannot move here it it will
be Checkmate anyway no that was very
very very smart comment okay why to play
in this position actually let's just
let's just make it tiny
bit let's just protect I need to protect
one Pawn here if not it will be tiny
tiny bit trickier so you will allow me
to bit modify this
position okay I think here we will be
very okay white is to play him very
similar to the previous
position
just like before I want to see two more
hands and then one two more hands and
you will so first
okay another hand okay one more
hand one more hand that is not yours not
the left or the right one that was a
great
one amazing okay you can
answer x f Rook takes
Knight
okay the queen is going to take it and
then excellent job now question how many
points of material white one here three
exactly exactly this is a tiny second is
actually tiny but just for half a move
before we played Bishop take Knight we
actually exchanging pieces with the same
value here why is saying oh you know
Take Five Points just for three but I'm
going to take five points on the next
move so we see that we have the same
idea either a fork or a double attack
but we need to tiny bit tiny bit work
for that which other ideas like that
this was fork and double attack which
other tactical ideas like this do we
know do we
have any other ideas that like that that
will help us win
material for example what about a
pin is a pin something that can help us
win material yes
um I
think
this position not important we're
speaking about other ideas this position
we take and we are just okay what about
pin now let me show you first question
what is a
pin uh something that you keep cornered
like you can't you have to keep a piece
there and if you don't you lose the
greater value of piece okay this this is
a normal pin and there is an absolute
pin what is an absolute pin yes if you
move that piece exactly so so it's so
it's just technically illegal to play
the move basically here let's just put
it without setting the entire book Let's
just put this position okay just focus
on the right rook and the bishop and the
King black cannot move this bishop it's
just illegal right because if the bishop
moves black is in check now what about
this position here I I changed the king
to Queen can black move the bishop now
yes is it going to be smart
no but he can so the previous one was an
absolute pin cannot do anything and this
one was just a pin okay so let's look at
how we can win material because you know
like I've said I can see your ages I can
see that you know you know your part of
Chess to win games to play well in
tournaments winning those winning
material in this way not blundering is
what
you can what you should be thinking for
many many many years white to play White
is a great move here to play
here yes Bishop to C3 Bishop to
C3 what what is so great about Bishop C3
because it's if the Rook moves it's
attacking The Rook cannot move so so we
so The Rook cannot move and if the Rook
cannot move then what's going to happen
on the next
move what would white play on the next
move check just take it right yeah yeah
we don't we don't make pins because wow
you get 10 pins you call the tournament
director and say hey I won I pinned my
opponent 10 times doesn't go this way
you create pins you win material you win
material you have more units you have
more units you control the board better
you will win the game that's the way it
goes now even if the Rook could have
been defended I put the Knight here on
specifically it cannot even defend but
even if it could have been defended well
white is going to win two points right
okay so we created a pin that cannot be
defended now we can also use pins in
many many other ways white has an
excellent move to play in this
position which move should white
play yes Queen takes G6 but the but the
pawn will take your
queen
it uhuh what do you think Bishop takes
pawn bishop takes pawn and if the Rook
will take it the Rook could take back
and then the king can take
it so let's see that was excellent what
you said Queen take pawn and I was
asking you what happens if the pawn take
it but you weren't scared and you told
me correctly
that this Pawn you know it's like
annoyingly enough like those machines
that you put a dollar trying to get a
drink and only after you put it you see
out of order sign right that's a bit
frustrating so this this this Pawn is an
out of order side he cannot move he
spinned actually it's in check black in
check but the pawn cannot move anywhere
because it will open this diagonal so
this Pawn
has an
invisible out of order you know not
functioning sign that's why you can take
the pawn it's pinned it's not working
now the other continuation is actually
not working let's do it in our head
without moving the pieces we take a
pawn The Rook will take it the Rook will
take the Rook the king will take the
Rook basically we gave a rook and a
bishop for a rook and a pawn and even if
we take
and take let's see if someone can tell
me this without moving the
pieces visualizing is really important
we're going to
take black will take and then white is
going to play Queen take this Pawn which
black which move black is going to play
though no no no no I I'm not going to
take twice here I'm going to take once
Bishop take
Pawn The Rook is going to take take our
Bishop then we will play the Queen take
the pawn on G6 what will black play
then yes
King don't like it so much and so should
you not like it no that's important
let's see it's two moves ahead not
saying it's the easiest but we should be
able to think the bishop take Again The
Rook take and then our Queen will take
this
yes you lose two pawns but but which
move black will play because black has a
problem his King is in check and his
Rook is under attack King f8 King
f8 best got any other moves King King H
that was suggested and I didn't like
it
seven no let's see okay this is this is
something that we see a lot I know that
when I'm going to put the position on
the board now you're going to tell me
the right answers but our job and that's
one of the big benefits of Chess to
young kids the ability to visualize
things to see how the position how many
things we look without moving them
before I move it let's give one last
shot shoot Rook D7 only move that left
very good only move that left take
take take we had to see this position in
now head now I know that you're all
going to tell me oh King f8 is so
horrible because Queen take F7 Checkmate
and king h8 is not pretty because just
going to lose the rook and that's why
we're going to play only
move R G7 yes
I oh but but but I yeah I I I thought
that you said it but then I specifically
emphasized that we just took once but
okay no problem okay so this is our tiny
part about pins now we have many other
many many other tactical ideas and
that's why you see that when I I wasn't
joking when I said we need to practice
hundreds of hundreds of hundreds of
dozen each one each decent book has 500
puzzle 1,000 puzzles and you can get
them according to difficulty
and so which other ideas we did two of
the main one fork and double attack they
happen a lot pins happen a lot what
else skews perfect
perfect okay you
know what are
SKS they're basically somewhat like pin
usually you put meat tomatoes onions in
them it's probably lunchtime but okay
you know that's why my brain is thinking
in that direction
but it's basically it's it's actually
not like a fork it has to be either
straight or diagonal like basically
really like a skew that you put all
those tasty tasty Meats after that will
it's white to play and white has an
excellent excellent move to play here so
you that set skes will get first right
to answer that so Queen
A1 see straight line the king is going
to go somewhere and then
takeen we'll take the queen now skrews
can also happen on diagonals for example
let's say this was the position and
we'll make it
interesting okay why to
play yes Queen G1 check very
good and we're going to win the queen
this way right okay so we have double
attack Fork pin skewes what else very
good the skewes comment was excellent
what
else what about what you
yes hanging but hanging pieces is they
are just pieces that you can capture
without using any tactical idea right
and you are by the hanging pieces you
know let me be clear all those ideas
they're secondary to a simple capture if
we can just capture something for
free and I emphasize the word for free
because not every time we capture
something it's free if we can capture
something for free you don't need this
all those are working hard to be able to
capture something for free what about
discover threats or discovered checks
what are they what will they be yes when
you move one P or out of the way of
another piece doing ack or doing an
attack I couldn't say it better that's
exactly the way for
example white has a way to use a PIN to
win the
game and even Checkmate using a pin and
white has a way to use discovered check
to win the queen and win the game so you
can choose both of them yes you g okay
one say one I will let someone else say
the other Bishop takes G7 by the way
which one will that be will that be the
pin or will that be the discovered
check discovered right the queen is
potentially attacking the other Queen
right
but the bishop is
blocking you found a very smart way to
move the bishop with a force way The
Queen Is Not defended Bishop takes check
and also it's an ambush Ambush sounds
scary Bishop take
take we take the queen for free
excellent now how can we win the game
using a
pin queen queen
H6 okay black will play King
G8 black will play King G8 and then what
and
then you take you take Bishop with the
bishop why with the bishop this is a
brilliant idea very good before we had
seen a pin that white had a bishop on B3
and this Pawn was out of order this Pawn
could not move this Pawn cannot move
you're very very very correct very
correct but why with the bishop what
what what escap you you have any
anything against checkmating your
opponent in one move
no torturing him being cruel evil just
Checkmate right so that was actually a
cool position because we had several
several ideas that were working which
other ideas for example let's let's
finish with one last
idea now this
idea doesn't have much to do
with doesn't have much to do
with check with material but actually
has way more to do with going after
the the king going after the king
because puzzles can be used a lot mainly
to win material and for checkmates and
of course for defense purposes always I
just showed you it's the easiest way
usually to see puzzles in order to win
the game but puzzles or sorry tactics
can be used and many puzzles are the
same white is to play
here what shall we play with white here
we have several captures we have several
possibilities what shall we play with
white Bishop takes B7 Bishop take B
seven okay we have several possibilities
and what happens if the opponent just
capture back what did we
get not much you want to say something
oh will you same Bishop take Bishop the
queen take we are not getting too
much
yes Queen takes Rook Queen takes Rook
and what happens didn't you just give
your queen for a rook
Checkmate so by the way would that be
another type of removing of the defender
yes removing the guard removing the
guard but the the main theme Here will
be Checkmate on the back Rank and for
checkmate you will pay any price right
who cares that it is a queen for oh I
see a oh I see what the Rook down there
yeah yeah that's what we say
excellent job and you using terms I can
see that you're doing puzzles that you
are reading decent books because exactly
removal of the Guard Checkmate on the
back rank just like our or my basketball
hero Larry Bird you know the more that
you're going to practice the more that
you're going to do those the easier it's
going to be in the game and like I said
you know you do three a day three a day
20 a week it adds up to a thousand a
year
it will be almost impossible you'll have
to work super hard not to get much
better if you do constantly 20 puzzles a
week and you can do
[Music]
[Applause]
more